Medical education over the last 500 years,
the single most important factor is
mentoring and that each each young
student has someone who is a role model,
and I think that the department has been
incredibly excellent in having a huge
number of people who are role models to
the young students and house staff.
And the people, the teachers in the Department of
Medicine, have given of themselves freely
to the house staff and students,
and this is a vitally important part of
producing excellent young physicians.
One of the notable characteristics of people
who go into medicine is that they have a
very very low threshold of boredom, and
it takes continually new challenges
to keep them alive and interested.
And what teaching gives to
the faculty member is this continual
excitement and continual new things.
Most of the learning of faculty comes
from the house staff and students,
It's very much a two-way street.
But what the students and house staff provide to
the faculty is a continual way of
keeping them from getting bored,
because life in teaching is continually exciting.
I've come to think in fact that
the word "teaching" probably shouldn't
exist, that the word is "learning," and what
makes successful teachers are people with
whom the student has a mutual learning
experience. And so what keeps the faculty
at Emory from being bored is the
outstanding students and house staff that
we have and they thereby avoid one of
the big traps of going into something
like medicine where one can become
bored if you not careful.